plus de soixante dix ans après les faits
l'émotion est toujours là
côté sociétés et floue
[Musique]
quand j'ai assisté à ces scènes
je peux vous dire que j'étais devenu le
pire sur google courte
oui j'ai vibré jeter j'en ai pris plein
la gueule
encore une fois un sac de billes c'est
l'histoire vraie de joseph joffo 85 ans
aujourd'hui le petit garçon juif ne fuit
plus les nazis et son livre
autobiographique a été vendu à plus de
200 millions d'exemplaires partout dans
le monde
malgré ce succès une ombre planait sur
le tableau le premier film de 1973
adapté de son livre le film précédent
donné une mauvaise image de mon père je
ne le pourrais pas le tolérer
et puis si vous regardez aussi la scène
du curé l'entrain peut-être que monsieur
doyon était anticlérical du j'en sais
rien nous les clôtures et qu'on a
rencontrés et du monde tchèques loriol
il a vu les deux mots paumés
on est arrivé on s'est assis à côté de
lui les ss sont arrivés derrière nous il
a levé la main il a dit les enfants sont
avec moi ça suffisait c'était très bien
voilà donc il n'y avait pas de raison de
faire autrement
voilà je crois que remettre les choses
au point
c'était important pour moi pour cette
deuxième adaptation joseph joffo a co
écrit le scénario et il a suivi toutes
les étapes de la réalisation du film
afin qu'il soit le plus proche possible
de son histoire
joseph joffo se dit aujourd'hui surpris
par le succès de son livre
au départ ils étaient destinés à sa
famille et ses amis puis le manuscrit a
été refusée 14 fois par des maisons
d'édition
aujourd'hui joseph joffo ne boude pas
son plaisir sur demande de la mairie de
saint cyr sur loire
le tourangeau de coeur compte participer
à une projection du nouveau sac de
billes fin février